hello and welcome to a small clip from
our weekly Game of Thrones show game
spot of Thrones for the whole episode
make sure to head over to youtube.com
slash game spot and we'll see you there
but there are loads of really good
theories about bran first of all that he
because he can see into the past and
have these green same visions that he
might be the old man in the tree he
might be the three-eyed Raven which i
think is quite interesting because you
never actually see the old the old guy
move from the waist down but there's an
interesting theory going around that
that is old bran and that he's using his
green seeing to go back in time and tell
young bran not to basically stay in too
long and get stuck in the tree but yeah
this is what happened so what if that
goes wrong and then there's a third
version of bran that comes out right
there and it goes you guys so fit like
skeleton days so speaking of time travel
paradoxes cuz that's where I'm going
I write basically you ain't get all
time-travel II and I normally hate that
I really honestly I hate time travel as
a plot device this is interesting though
it's sort of like it's a thing called a
stable time loop where you don't know
what comes first chicken or egg
so Bryan if he can use his visions to go
back in time we know that so like you
know the scene where he he says father
and he looks around and he's like oh was
it the wind or can Bryan actually like
talk to people through these his visions
his dreams so if he can do that what if
he went back in time in a vision and he
spoke to King Aerys Mad King Aerys so
the reason basically that all of the
events that Game of Thrones
as we know are happening is because Mad
King Aerys burned Rickon and Brandon
stark alive so that's brands grandfather
and his uncle and that's what sparked
off like Robert's rebellion like Rhaegar
Lyanna that whole thing start from like
that one scenario so wife bran went back
in time and was like talking to King
Aerys trying to get him to stop doing
that but because King Aerys is mad
he like just thinks it's voices in his
head just burns them so what if bran
like keeps going back in time to try and
fix things and he actually ends up
making it worse what I'm saying is what
if all of Game of Thrones is brands
fault yeah Jesus he's like Marty McFly
this whole thing this is going back
messing things up yeah the stuff in the
books where Brown goes to visit his dad
like through the weirwood tree and he
talks to him and Ned will react and
we've seen more of this in the show
which kind of hints that bran has like
stronger power than we thought you did
but you guys think the time travel at
least at this point is a cop-out it
seems a bit clumsy yeah I do of being
able to talk to the past rather than
travel mmm that seems a little cleaner
but then you get to the whole thing like
paradoxes I mean the stable timely means
that like the event in the past happened
and because that's happened the event in
the future happens that allows you to go
in the past
it's a chicken-and-egg you don't know
which is the thing that starts it yeah
so he thinks he's going back to stop his
grandfather being burned when actually
he's the cause yeah so that's why it
happens and if he didn't go it wouldn't
happen but he has to go because he
already did so yeah so like he's gone
either back burns and then he tries to
go back and change it yeah in doing so
he cause he goes in this yeah this is
like I just find this theory really
really interesting I mean of all the
weird things that Game of Thrones has
introduced I wouldn't put it past them
to have some like this mmm like I said
it needs to be something quite so like
speaking as the past Robin yeah yeah if
it does happen though I kind of want him
to go to every single huge event in Game
of Thrones like he goes to Rhaegar at
the the paranal Tony I mean he goes
don't think Lyanna stark is hot and he
goes Leona stop she is hot she is real
hot and you're like brand-new so do you
think he's actually gone back in time to
tell his old self not to climb the tower
yeah and then that was actually this
turned round and looked at yeah exactly
basically everything is Brian's fault
you all do that
you